um who who do you listen to right now
not not like your alltime greats but
like who's just like some music if if we
were to open up your Spotify or apple
music like what did you do your your
recap like your personal recap like who
were your top five I don't even stream
music I I listen to music on YouTube I
don't stream music that's the crazy part
yeah a lot of people are like that like
I don't know why YouTube doesn't do a
recap yeah I don't stream music on on um
those things but I do stream music on
YouTube and so what you listening to I
listen to um of course my playlist is
like Drake do cat cardi
B ice Bice I listen to a lot of Billy
iish Billy ish shout out to her yeah
that's my I love her Billy ish is fire
yeah I just be listening to music on um
on YouTube and stuffff YouTube and stuff
you know who I like right now that's hot
in New York this guy um he um bro hold
on let me talk bro moving stiff when he
walk I think it's Jay hound and J5 that
sounds like what you just did right now
sounds like so many New York rappers
hold on Yo am I crazy you can can you
give me some insight
here I feel like there's so many rappers
who just sound like pop smoke now not
like the way they rap or what their but
their voice mhm it's like there's so
much like we went to New York we hung
out with Dusty L Kaine he sounds like
popm smoke and he knows this he's the
homie free Dusty Lane uh what was the
other guy rwi Ross swish sounds like
popm smoke so it's like is this like
something in the water where everyone's
got a [__] deep raspy voice it's
crazy you know what I think it's just
because Us New Yorkers we talk away so
it's like if you hear somebody
from Chicago or something and you'll be
like oh they all rap the same or
something like that it's not that they
all rap I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
talking about their voice their voice
their talking voice I mean I don't know
maybe
it's it's like it's crazy bro it's like
now shout out to them though because
they really be putting the city on uh
you got a lot of big homies in the rap
game we already talked about Buster
rymes uh any other uh guys who have you
know obviously embraced you and given
you some some game um yeah there's a lot
of people like I don't I got a 50
Cent shout out to 50 Cent what 50 tell
you they teach you how to be Petty
pettiest [__] alive right there
I love it I just study his the way he
like he's just a genius you feel me oh
he is I think he's going to buy Revolt
from Diddy by the way that's my
prediction it's going to happen I just
feel like one day we're going to wake up
and Diddy's goingon to own or Diddy's
going to sell Revolt to 50 I don't know
we'll see I just think he's that kind of
petty but you know anybody else besides
50 oh yeah I performed that Revol before
shout out to that that was a fun
experience hopefully not too fun and
them people in Atlanta they was [__]
with me too I was like back the [__] up
move the [__] back